Democrats unwittingly opened the door
for a hunter Biden's testimony while
targeting Donald Trump Bernie Green
gains ground in New Hampshire and Bernie
comes under fire for touting a Joe Rogan
endorsement i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected and Express at VPN comm / Ben
well I know you're yawning because after
all we're still covering impeachment why
the hell are we covering impeachment I
know it's supposed to be SuperDuper
important but here is the reality people
are bored now I know the media's gonna
tell you that this is a figment of the
right-wing imagination that actually
people are on tenterhooks but the
ratings do not lie the ratings continue
to be abysmal for what is supposed to be
one of the great historic moments in
American history the moment when Adam
Schiff saved the Republic I do not think
that the American people are tuned in to
this thing I don't think the American
people care deeply I think all of this
is baked into the cake at this point so
the fact that the Democrats keep trying
to sell this thing like the
entertainment press is trying to sell
female Ghostbusters is entertaining to
me it's also entertaining to me how the
Democrats have decided to ramp up the
theatrics so in the end the case that
they are making about president Trump is
not completely implausible right there
they're making the case that Trump tried
to pressure the president of Ukraine
into going after Joe Biden to benefit
Trump in 2020 solely that is their case
now is that a plausible read it's not
totally implausible but is it
evidentiary based no it is not and when
you are trying to prove a case you
actually have to provide the entire
chain of evidence the Democrats have
knots on that and so instead what
they're doing is al pacino and and
justice for all
banging the table yelling at the moon
there's no quarters out of work so you
have Adam Schiff who is just a partisan
hat I mean a real partisan hack a man
who as I've said before went on
television for two years claiming he had
secret information that was going to
damned President Trump to impeachment
for a collusion with Russia we have Adam
Schiff pretending to be a leader of the
moral hierarchy in the United States and
the Adam Schiff the same fellow who
within the last week has openly lied
about contents he knew he was lying
about notes from left Parnas to Rudy
Giuliani concerning a meeting with the
head of Purisima he pretended as a
meeting with the head of Ukraine Adam
Schiff the same guy who was pretty much
openly cooperating his office was with
the whistleblower and then pretending he
had no idea who the whistleblower was
and all of this which I don't believe
for half a second Adam Schiff a deeply
dishonest human being he was out there
making his closing argument
tonight and it was as dishonest as you
would suspect but it was also as
emotional as you would suspect he took
CNN Tayna bashes Dana Bash had a
suggestion yesterday she said the
American people they don't seem all that
invest in this what we need is we need
more props and more emotion we need the
Democrats to get up there and do an
episode of The Muppet Show I should need
Kermit the Frog talking about Donald
Trump in Ukraine Miss Piggy Oh Kermit
and then in background you can have the
two old guys up in the balcony going
this show is terrible
ah ha ha and then the American people
would actually be interested in this
thing so Adam Schiff put on his own
Muppet eyes and decided that he would go
for it that he was going to really up
the emotion here is Adam Schiff choking
up now do you believe that Adam Schiff
is actually getting choked up here do
you believe that Adam Schiff yeah before
a prosecutor a longtime Congress person
that he is actually getting emotional
hear that Adam Schiff is just Hughes
overwhelmed with that he was so overcome
with the moment and he was getting
choked up because morality matters and
right matters okay if you believe this
you're an idiot seriously if you believe
in the emotion of politicians generally
you're an idiot
the only time I've ever seen politicians
get truly emotional and I thought okay
this is pretty real is when George W
Bush after 9/11 because everybody was so
shaken up by 9/11 or you might say like
Edmund muskie in 1972 when his actual
family's being attacked like I believe
it when Joe Biden gets pissed about
hunter Biden or Beau Biden I totally get
it right that somebody attacks your
family that is a place where you are
going to get upset but do I believe it
when politicians on the grand stage in
their closing argument suddenly turn
into Jimmy Stewart from mr. Smith goes
to Washington no I don't believe that
for a second because Jimmy Stewart was
an actor and you know what this is what
we call acting hey Jon Lovitz acting
here we go Adam Schiff acting here right
is supposed to matter
it's what's made us the greatest nation
on earth no Constitution can protect us
right doesn't matter anymore and you
know you can't trust this president do
what's right for this country if you
find him guilty you must find that he
should be removed because right matters
because right matters and the truth
matters otherwise we are lost oh my god
yes oh and people were going gaga for
this this trended okay right matters
trended because oh it was not scripted
it was just a spontaneous moment it was
moment mr. Smith goes to Washington
Claude Rains in the back room shooting
himself like that
or alternatively this was highly
produced and really silly and quite
ridiculous and again the whole argument
is quite ridiculous and self
contradictory because when you actually
look at what Adam Schiff said yesterday
so many of the things that he said were
just not true so here was a Adam Schiff
for example talking about Barack Obama's
Ukraine policy so one of the points that
the Trump team has made is that you keep
complaining about the Trump team's
treatment of Ukraine you keep
complaining that team Trump is really
really mean to Ukraine
well team Trump provided actual killing
aid to Ukraine like military aids
Ukraine that included weaponry capable
of protecting them against the Russians
which is something the Obama
administration did not do and you go to
Adam Schiff saying no no you'd
understand
Obama rallied the world against Russia
invading Ukraine really did he because
it seems to me that Russia is still in
Crimea like now today and that rallying
the world involved president Trump
basically doing nothing for months on
end and then every so often saying that
it was very very bad that Russia was
doing a very bad thing which is exactly
what he did in Syria also so here is
Adam Schiff just lying about Barack
Obama's record President Obama used his
calls with foreign leaders to contain
the fallout from the global economic
crisis assemble an international
coalition to fight the Islamic state and
of course to rally support for Ukraine
following Russia's invasion of Crimea no
matter what you think of the policy
views or priorities of these prior
residents there is no question that they
are examples of the normal diplomacy
that happens during presidential
telephone calls and then there's the
normal diplomacy that happens when
you're on the stage with Dmitri Medvedev
and telling him that you'll offer his
country flexibility after he lit the
election so long as they back off before
the election that was the part that Adam
Schiff didn't play on tape but he's a
deeply honest man right
right yeah we can get to more of Adam
Schiff and Jerry Nadler and the rest of
the Democrats also I got to tell you
about this this amazing controversy that
is now broken out over my friend Joe
Rogan apparently Joe Rogan is now
cancelled which you knew was coming but
canceled for the most bizarre ease and
it's pretty incredible get to that in
just one second first let's be real
about this if you have a medical issue
sitting around and waiting on medical
issue is a stupid idea you should go get
a medical issue solved even if that
issue happens to be embarrassing to you
now listen guys don't want to talk about
erectile dysfunction why would you want
to you don't want to talk about that
with people you know it may be it's hard
to even talk about that with a doctor
well good news for you you can head on
over to get Roman comm right now and you
can get it done really fast and really
quickly and confidentially as well also
right now people in the unit in the
United States are waiting to see a
doctor for weeks at a time
sometimes a month sometimes well if
you're dealing with a condition like IDI
you want treatment ASAP which is why our
friends at Roman who spent years
building a digital platform that can
connect you with the doctor licensed in
your state all from the comfort of home
Roman makes it convenient to get the
treatment you need on your schedule just
grab your phone or computer complete a
free online visit you'll hear back from
a u.s. licensed physician within 24
hours if the doctor decides that
treatments is right for you
Romans pharmacy can ship your medication
to you with free two-day shipping you
also get free unlimited follow-ups with
your doctor anytime you have questions
or want to adjust your treatment plan
with Roman there are no commitments and
you can cancel anytime again
medical issues get them solved so if
you're struggling with edie hair loss
cold sores even other issues go to get
Roman comm /ban for a free online visit
again that's get Roman comm /ban get
this done quickly you got it done easily
and get it taken care of why exactly we
should be sitting around waiting on it
okay speaking of the atom shift pushing
silliness so Adam Schiff also made the
case that President Trump was pushing
Russian propaganda about Ukrainian
interference in the election now I think
that President Trump buys into
confirmation bias in an extraordinary
way I think the President Trump
bought into a bunch of stories about all
the stuff that was happening in Ukraine
and a lot of those stories were not true
the conspiracy theory that CrowdStrike
was a Ukrainian operated business that
was hiding the reality the Ukrainian
hacks Hillary Clinton's server that
Hillary Clinton's actual server was
buried in a forest outside Kiev or some
such nonsense
I agree that that's nonsense but the
Democrats really overplayed their hand
here when they suggest that there was no
Ukrainian interference in the election
we know that there was Ukrainian
interference in the election Politico
reported there was Ukrainian
interference in the election the two-can
are not mutually exclusive and that's
not to say that the Ukrainian
interference was anything like on the
magnitude of the Russian interference it
was not but for the Democrats to
overplay this thing and then say there
was no interference which is what they
now have to claim in order that they can
say that it was really about donald
trump trying to manufacture information
about joe biden for 2020 they have to
fib so here's Adam chef fibbing a little
bit what the president is talking about
here is a very specific conspiracy
theory going to the server itself
meaning that it was Ukraine that hacked
the Democratic server not the Russians
this theory was brought to you by the
Kremlin okay so we're not talking about
generic interference we're talking about
the server we're talking about
CrowdStrike at least that's what Donald
Trump wanted investigated or announced
this completely bogus Kremlin pushed
conspiracy theory and so again the
reason that he is saying this is because
if he acknowledges that maybe there
could be legit interest in what Ukraine
did and maybe what Trump was doing even
if it was based on wrong information was
not badly motivated and the problem is
the Democrats have to assume motive in
order to get where they want to go right
here meanwhile the Democrats are opening
the door to testimony by hunter Biden so
Sylvia Garcia representative Garcia
she's one of the other impeachment
managers in the House and she like Adam
Schiff they do not want hunter Biden to
testify so they want to have it both
ways they want to have left harness
testify they want to have Mick Mulvaney
as well get to testify they want
everybody to testify
except for Hunter Biden they do not want
hunter Biden to testify and so they've
been making the argument that hunter
Biden should not testify because they're
trying to
protect Joe Biden Cheryl geese Stolberg
reporting for The New York Times House
Democrats sought on Thursday to
preemptively dismantle president Trump's
Court defenses in his impeachment trial
invoking his own words to argue that his
pressure campaign on Ukraine was an
abuse of power that warranted his
removal Democrats sought to make the
case that Trump's actions were an
affront to the Constitution and they
worked to disprove his lawyers claim
that he was acting only in the nation's
interest when he sought to enlist
Ukraine to investigate political rivals
in doing so they took a calculated risk
in talking at length about president
Trump's targets including former VP Joe
Biden and his son hunter Biden and
underscored the political backdrop of a
trial unfolding only 10 months before
the election and likely to reverberate
long after the verdict and in that line
see here's Sylvia Garcia pretending that
there is nothing to investigate about
hunter Biden no reason to be concerned
about hunter Biden the Democrats are
playing a dangerous game here because
once they say we want additional
witnesses and then they say we don't
want hunter Biden people are going to
say okay why why is the central issue
here not being addressed here is Sylvia
Garcia opening the door wide even if the
president wanted an investigation of
hunter Biden there is no basis for that
either now how do you know
well Ukraine's former prosecutor general
admitted that the allegation against
Vice President Biden's son was plainly
false even the Ukrainians believe that
Biden's son did nothing wrong
we got a couple problems here one some
Ukrainians say that hunter Biden did
nothing wrong and Joe Biden did nothing
wrong then you have other prosecutors
like Victor Shokan the one that Biden
went after who is actually apparently
selling the information that Biden did
do something wrong also if your line is
that the Ukrainians said that hunter
Biden and Joe Biden did nothing wrong
you know who has said that Donald Trump
did nothing wrong
all of ukrainian leadership so if you're
gonna cite the Ukrainian leadership to
the affected hunter Biden and Joe Biden
off the hook the same people have also
said that Donald Trump is off the hook
but you don't cite them in support of
one proposition but you said but you
cite them in support of the other
proposition so all of this is a bit of a
mess
for the Democrats we're gonna get to
more of this in just one second first
let us talk about why cyber security
should be an issue for you why you
should really pay attention to your own
cybersecurity so we hear the Daily wire
we spend tons of
and tons of time protecting our
cybersecurity because we're major
company and we come under attack on a
fairly regular basis but why should you
worry about that you're not a major
company well here's the answer there a
lot of hackers want your personal
information in fact a lot of people who
will make more money off of stealing
your personal information off of your
computer then they will trying to hack a
big company it takes a lot of resources
to hack a big company takes no resources
to Accu right they can do it very easily
on public Wi-Fi they can do it using
backdoors there are all sorts of ways
they can get your information this is
why you need to be using a VPN and not
just for hackers because why would you
want all the social media companies
gathering data from you and then
monetizing it why would you want the
government keeping track of everything
that you do online instead check out
expressive VPN it's the software I and
thousands of my fans use every day to
protect our data online in the time
since I started using expressvpn hacking
methods keep growing more and more
sophisticated expressvpn keeps working
to keep the hackers out I've been
talking about expressvpn on the show for
a really long time you should be using
it I've use it all the time literally
every time I go online my only question
is why haven't you done this yet visit
my special link right now and expressvpn
calm /ban get an extra three months of
expressvpn for free it works really
quickly on your computers not going to
slow down your computer it works easily
you click one button and you're now
protected protect your internet today
with the VPN I trust to keep my data
safe go to Express at VPN comm slash pen
get an extra three months for free that
is expressive VPN calm slash Ben I talk
about them all the time just do it
expressvpn calm slash mem now the
Democrats again are trying to manipulate
the process more than a little bit here
and the way that they are doing this is
they are targeting people deliberately
whom they know have executive privilege
specifically so that they can claim that
obstruction is going on this is the the
argument being made by Senator Tom
cotton this is obviously true right they
did this in the house it would say that
they wanted a particular witness the
witness would say well I'm gonna appeal
that to a court and then the Democrats
would say we don't want you to appeal it
to a court and now you're obstructing
we're not gonna go through the process
and also you're obstructing well now it
looks like what the Democrats want to do
is call people like Mick Mulvaney the
the chief of staff or John Bolton people
who are subject to executive privilege
particularly on foreign policy executive
privilege does run pretty wide Tom
cotton says what Democrats are doing
right here is they're attempting to call
people who will cite executive privilege
so they can then
claim that obstruction is taking place
the Democrats have not sought the
testimony of Rudy Giuliani a private
citizen or say secretary Rick Perry or
Secretary Mike Pompeo who regularly
testify in front of Congress why are
they going after the president's closest
advisors those most likely subject to
executive privilege it's because they
care more about trying to create a
campaign issue against Republican
senators and then they care about
getting relevant testimony 'no okay and
again and that is underscored by the
fact that they keep saying that hunter
Biden should not testify and Lindsey
Graham who is fairly close with Joe
Biden I mean they're pretty friendly she
says listen I don't think Joe Biden is
corrupt but we sort of have to ask the
question at this point and let's be
straight about this if hunter Biden was
named Donald Trump jr. and he was doing
all the stuff right now wouldn't the
Democrats be taking precisely the
opposite position here senator Graham
from the time they raided the
president's home Joe Biden called the
president of Ukraine four times got on a
plane and said if you don't fire this
guy you don't get the billion dollars I
love Joe Biden but I can tell you if the
name was Trump there'd be a lot of
questions asked
I don't think Joe Biden's corrupt but I
don't think he's beyond being looked at
here's what I would say how many members
of the body his children are on foreign
boards receiving this kind of money
okay then again these are legit
questions senator Ted Cruz saying the
same thing and the Democrats keep saying
we're not going to allow hunter Biden to
testify it's irrelevant he's not going
to testify
senator Cruz keeps saying okay well that
is the president's defense and now
you're trying to deny him his main
defense which is that he was
legitimately interested in corruption in
Ukraine including hunter Biden's
corruption here as senator Cruz Atom
shifts arguments to open the day to day
directly drew into question hunter Biden
and made not only his testimony relevant
which it already was but it is now
critical because the House Democrats
have built their entire case on the
proposition that any investigation into
Brisa and corruption was a sham that it
was completely debunked the problem is
there is very significant prima facie
evidence of corruption okay well we'll
find out because again if we called
additional witnesses I think there's
very little doubt hunter Biden ends up
on the stand and the very least that's
not gonna look great for Joe Biden no
matter whether Joe Biden did something
wrong whether he didn't see something
wrong doesn't look great when you're
flying your squiring your son around
he's using your last name to pick up
bags of cash in foreign countries
meanwhile the other big news from
impeachment gate is that CBS Evening
News is reporting that apparently
somebody and it's unclear who's somebody
either a Republican in the Senate or a
Republican in the White House is telling
people in the Senate thinner head will
be on a pike that their head will be on
a pike if they oppose President Trump in
this impeachment effort now why that
exactly is newsworthy is beyond me
honestly like I understand that the
language is very colorful but do you
think that those sorts of threats do not
happen literally every single day in the
legislature why do you think that people
back down before Nancy Pelosi do you
think it's because she we Dalls them or
do you think that she says guess what
I'm not gonna fundraise for you and the
guillotine is prepared in the back room
you can say what you want and I'm saying
is that your head may not be connected
to your body right they you can't
portray her as the queen of dragons
without there being a little bit of a
threat involved which is exactly the way
the Democrats have portrayed Nancy
Pelosi for years but apparently it's
very very bad for the White House to
employ its leverage over over
Republicans now listen would it be
better would we live in a better world
if nobody ever applied leverage to their
own Congress people and everybody just
voted their conscience of course has
that ever been the way that American
politics works or any other politics for
that matter not in the slightest so
treating this as a shock that the White
House or that Mitch McConnell's office
is trying to apply leverage to its own
members why exactly is that shocking
they literally do this on every bill on
every bill you attempted to apply
leverage it's just a question of degree
nonetheless CBS News reported that
senators were warned they don't they
don't say by whom an unnamed source
close to the president which could be
anybody right really anybody it could be
somebody who is a staffer for the
president could be George Conway cuz
he's close to the president by proxy it
could be anybody telling CBS News that
apparently senators were warned quote
vote against the president in your head
will be on a pike and then the Daily
Mail reports it's unclear from the
report whether the warning was issued by
the White House or Republican leadership
in the Senate so we don't even know who
issued the warning it could've been just
some guy on a street corner going here
head will be on a pike and CBS News is
like well that's a threat that's a
threat what does that mean does anybody
actually believe that President Trump is
gonna stomp on over to the Senate he's
gonna take out a broad axe and he's
gonna start going to town if somebody
votes against him on impeachment no it
means that he's applying political
pressure which again if you think
political pressure was not applied on
Democrats during the Clinton impeachment
route your mind
political pressure is always applied
that's the nature of politics but this
is now being used as a case in point of
Trumpy and intimidation when in reality
that's just the nature of politics
what's more interesting than that report
and this one is not getting any play is
the fact that Democrats are not
approaching any of the moderate
Republicans the Washington Post reports
that the most closely watched Senators
of president Trump's impeachment trial
are oddly isolated they say the
president Trump is keeping his distance
because White House advisers are telling
him that outreach wouldn't help his
cause which is obviously truth from
calls up Susan Collins she's going to
say that he is trying to intimidate her
and she's gonna stand up to him right if
he calls up Mitt Romney that's not gonna
go great for him but meanwhile Democrats
say there is no serious effort to
privately lobby the Republicans with the
party instead relying on public opinion
and the House prosecutors to squeeze
them into breaking ranks what does that
go to show it shows that they know that
they're not gonna get those Republican
senators on their side they're just
trying to gin up public sentiment in
advance of the 2020 elections that's
really what that is about right if the
Democrats truly cared about trying to
win this impeachment vote they'll be out
there lobbying the Democrat the
Republican senators like day in and day
out but they're not doing any of that
instead they are pushing a different
idea which is public opinion right
they're trying to push public opinion to
push the senators which really suggest
that this isn't about winning the
impeachment battle at all
really what this is about in effect is
trying to undercut those senators for
purposes of 2020 which of course is what
this entire thing is about in the first
place okay in just one second I'm gonna
get to the 2020 race because frankly all
of this is about the 2020 race and there
is a fascinating example of the left
shooting itself directly in the foot
because they cannot help themselves
truly cannot help themselves it's
amazing
we'll get to that in just one second
first we're three days into this
impeachment trial it is clear that the
Democrats are gonna manipulate this
thing with everything they've got the
media are going to help them out if
you'd like to know the real truth and
get a behind-the-scenes look into
everything happening check out the newly
released podcast verdict
with Ted Cruz senator Cruz and the Daily
wires ohm useless Michel moles take you
behind the scenes of the capital give
you exclusive conservative insight are
the most important political stories of
the day finally made Knowles useful
here's a little bit of the trailer join
senator Ted Cruz as he breaks down the
most important political stories of the
day on his new podcast verdict if you
get to the heart of the problem with the
House Democrats case here it's that they
have an alleged treason bribery or other
high crimes or misdemeanors and let's
actually talk about what the
constitutional standard is subscribe
today and leave a five star review for
verdict with Ted Cruz co-hosted by me
Michael Knowles on Apple podcasts
Spotify and everywhere else you get your
podcasts I know that that podcast is
soaring up the charts be sure to go
check it out on Apple podcast Spotify or
your favorite streaming service again
it's called verdict with Ted Cruz and
really is a good inside look at what
exactly is going on on a day to day
level in the Senate okay meanwhile in
the 2020 race I am amused by the radical
left I'm amused by them so yesterday Joe
Rogan who's a friend of mine right full
disclosure I'm friends with Joe I think
Joe's good dude we disagree on a wide
variety of topics but what's fun about
Joe is that Joe is really open-minded
he's willing to discuss with anybody
like he'll have anybody on the show
he'll have tons of people from a variety
of different viewpoints he's had me he's
had Bernie Sanders he said Barry Weiss
and he's had and he's had people who I
think are wildly not Barry Weiss I mean
he's he's had people from virtually
every area of life well Joe Rogan was
asked by Barry Weiss on his show who he
would be likely to vote for in the
California primaries and here was Joe
Rogan's answer I think I'll probably
vote for Bernie him as a human being
when I was hanging out with him and yeah
I believe in him I like him I like him a
lot
what Bernie stands for is a guy who look
you could you could dig up dirt on every
single human being that's ever existed
if you catch them in their worst moment
and you magnify those moments and you
cut out everything else and you only
display those display those worst
moments that said you can't find very
many with Bernie he's been insanely
consistent his entire life okay so Rogan
is saying what really is Bernie's appeal
which
the Bernie has been this old commie for
his entire life now I don't find that
appealing right I think that his ideas
have been bad since basically he emerged
from his mother's womb at age 82 but
like he's like the high school principal
and back to the future the man never had
hair right I mean that's that's he was
always like this but that is his appeal
right yeah the appeal of Bernie is the
authenticity it's the reason why people
have not turned to Elizabeth Warren they
feel she is inauthentic people who like
Bernie believe that he is authentic and
so they're like okay at least he
believes what he believes and that goes
a long way with Jo now again I disagree
with Jo on this I think Bernie Sanders
is a trashy
I think he's awful I think he associates
with the worst people I think that he
champions the worst people but what's
hilarious is the left which has no
problem whatsoever
with Bernie Sanders hanging out with
Linda Sarsour no problem with him being
endorsed by Shawn King no problem with
Bernie Sanders touting the endorsements
of some of the most radical people in
American life Joe Rogan said that right
he said I'd be likely to vote for Bernie
Sanders and Bernie Sanders had the
temerity to put that up on a sweater
page and now that is trending number one
on Twitter
number one not because Rogan said that
he'd be likely to vote for Sanders
that's not actually a huge surprise
right Joe isn't out of the box dude
that's not it really is not super
shocking and authenticity matters an
awful lot to Joe the reason people are
mad is because Joe Rogan has had people
like me on his show and the fact that
Joe Rogan has had people like me on a
show means that Joe Rogan is a very bad
man who's very bad and very bad and that
means that Bernie Sanders touting his
endorsement is really awful because Joe
Rogan believes things like sometimes he
says that men are men and women are
women and that men should not fight
women in MMA that's the thing he has
said and that is quite terrible and also
Joe Rogan is a comedian which means he
has said very politically correct and
offensive things in the past and that is
very bad and so now Bernie Sanders is
being attacked by the woke left for the
sin of touting the fact that the most
popular podcaster in America right I
mean Joe is huge that Joe came out and
said that he would vote for Bernie in a
primary or as likely to vote in a
primary the left is so self-defeating
and Bernie deserves every bit of this of
course because burning his core to this
right for all the talk about Bernie's
authenticity here's where Joe I think is
wrong bernie is is authentic until the
point where he has challenged at which
point he backs down like a little pansy
right he is absolutely authentic until
the point where he's attacked on it and
then he runs screaming from the room to
give an example he was endorsed by by
Chiang Kai grrrrrr so and I have
our disagreements
to put it mildly you can find a debate
with me and chanc online it's pretty fun
to make Hey shank is running for
Congress out here in California he also
has a big show called The Young Turks
which is weird since for a long time he
didn't believe in the Armenian Genocide
but in any case Schenk has a long
history of saying pretty wild things
okay but chunk was always a Sanders
supporter right he always supported
Sanders right it's like he's always
supported him and so chanc endorse
Sanders Sanders said thank you and then
people started filling up Sanders his
feed with all the things that chanc has
said over the years and Sanders
basically withdrew his endorsement of
the endorsement
he basically disassociated from Chang
which is the most gutless move in the
entire world means super duper gutless
it's not like Chang was hiding the ball
Chang has been Chang forever yeah the
same thing with Rogan I would not be
surprised if Bernie Sanders backs off of
this I would not be surprised if Bernie
Sanders pulls down the tweet and says
while I'm grateful for Joe Rogan support
I don't agree with everything that Joe
Blow good side ba-ba-ba-ba that would
not be surprising to me at all
this is and he deserves that I mean
that's what he has he has facilitated
the rise of this woke left he has he
didn't have to he could've been the guys
standing up to it but he has facilitated
that rise he has catered to that rise
and now he's feeling the blowback from
him so fine but it is amazing that the
world the left wants to create it really
is an incredible world
I mean Rogan has had on a variety of
Democratic candidates and many of the
candidates have asked to come on and he
has said I don't really want you to come
right but Andrea give you another
example of how the woke left is ruining
America
so Andrew yang hey Andrew yang is
according to the Emerson poll now
running forth ready has like eight
percent to national polls according to
some polls which is amazing for a dude
who has been completely shut out of the
media Andrew yang had the temerity to
appear with me on a Sunday special where
he had an hour-long discussion of
universal basic income that was
completely cordial and interesting and
fun and informative it has millions of
views online he was blasted for the sin
of that blasted for it one of the
reasons Andrew yang is popular is
because Andrew yang is willing to have
conversations with people who disagree
without demonizing them meanwhile he get
people to judge people who judge has
catered to the woke left every step of
the way very early on in the campaign
when he first announced I invited people
who to judge to come on the sunday
special and his campaign manager said
he'd love to come on the Sunday special
because at that point
had no attention and then they got so
much blowback did he just ghost it right
then it was like nope
don't exist anymore not interested in
coming on not even respond to emails
okay that is not how you build a
coalition obviously but the Democrats
are not interested in building a
coalition the woke Democrats at least
coalition and let's be frank about this
I hate giving advice to Democrats let's
be frank about this Democrats if you are
going to force Joe Rogan out of your
circle if you're gonna say that Joe
Rogan cannot you cannot tout an
endorsement from Joe Rogan because he
said some bad things about her men are
men and women are women good luck to you
good luck to you you're gonna have to
win some people like Joe Rogan if you
hope to win an election and you want to
push Joe Rogan over to my side of the
aisle keep doing this kind of stuff
seriously you want to push people like
Joe Rogan people like Andrew yang over
to my side of the aisle all you have to
do is keep being vicious jackasses all
the time and dredging up old comment and
then suggesting well this person is very
bad this is a very bad person and it's
incredible how the media not only go
along with this but facilitate all of
this so Sam Stein who is a quote-unquote
reporter with The Daily Beast which is
to say that he is an activist with The
Daily Beast it's pretty incredible Sam
Stein had an exchange with Glenn
Greenwald okay Glenn Greenwald is hardly
a person with a with a sterling record
when it comes to controversy at the very
least he's a very controversial figure
Glenn Greenwald this is a guy who helps
Edward Snowden release documents at the
behest of the Russian government
allegedly right I mean Glenn Greenwald I
think he does some good work I think he
does some work that I disapprove of I
don't particularly like his point of
view at all I will note here by the way
that right now he's being prosecuted
Brazil that's completely inappropriate I
don't see any evidence that he's
violated the law in Brazil Here I am
defending somebody I completely disagree
with and I think his vicious views on a
variety of topics but Glenn Greenwald he
has an exchange with Sam Stein Sam
Stein's reporter for The Daily Beast
intense and Sam Stein starts criticizing
Bernie for the Rogan stuff right he
tweets out I totally see the merits in
Bernie touting the Joe Rogan endorsement
but I'm also deeply cognizant that I'm
not from a community of people that he
has attacked and ridiculed and I have to
imagine this is very hard for them very
hard for them they're just terrible
terrible okay and then
Greenwald responded quite appropriately
well you know it makes kind of sense
that he is that he is touting the
endorsement from Rogan because if you
actually want to win a coalition then
one of the things that you're gonna have
to do is appeal to people who may
disagree with you on a variety of other
topics and Sam Stein then responds so
would it be okay to tout an endorsement
from ben shapiro all right i mean that
like this is how far they've gone the
way that they have gone is first of all
I would never endorsed Bernie Sanders
but the thought experiment goes
something like this
if Joe Rogan who has said bad mean
things is endorsed by Bernie Sanders or
at least his endorsement is endorsed by
Bernie Sanders that's very bad where are
you gonna stop where is the line is the
line that you're going to say that it's
okay sits out an endorsement from ben
shapiro a sam stein alleged reporter for
The Daily Beast this is what the left
wants what the left wants is to circle
the wagons
shut that Overton Window so tight that
anybody who's outside that Overton
Window cannot ever be acknowledged as a
human being and to make it so that if
somebody endorses you you have to agree
with every one of their views in order
for you to accept the endorsement now
listen it would be perfectly appropriate
if neo-nazis endorsed endorsed Bernie
Sanders for Bernie to say I don't want
their endorsement right that's perfectly
appropriate there are certain views that
obviously are outside the bounds of
shall we say the mainstream in American
society men are men and women are women
is not outside the bounds of mainstream
in American society Joe Rogan is most
popular podcaster in America the fact
that the Democrats see fit to to go
after Bernie Sanders for the great sin
of acknowledging that people who
disagree on transgender issues might
support him have attic guys really enjoy
enjoy this is the world you want this is
the world you're gonna get and Bernie
Sanders will lose running away if he
caters to you guys at some point here
Bernie is actually gonna have to stand
on his hind legs it's amazing for a guy
who was considered so courageous when's
the last time he actually stood up on
his hind legs and said no to anybody who
wasn't the capitalist cuz it's the only
issue where he won't where he won't back
down is when he's ripping on capitalism
when it comes to the woke left there's
been no point anywhere along the line
here or he has just said nope this is
bunch of crap not one point anywhere
along the line instead he just caters
and caters and carrot we'll see I I have
my doubts that he's gonna stick by the
the Joe Rogan played I have a feeling
that he's probably gonna back down now
maybe he doesn't
he'd be a fool too he's kind of stuck
between a rock and a hard place now but
good luck good luck to Bernie Sanders
meanwhile team Obama is going after
Bernie Sanders to sew an ex Obama
campaign manager basically said that
Bernie is the worst candidate in the
field the war on Bernie has begun and
that war will not stop until Joe Biden
is the nominee here is a one of one of
Obama's ex campaign managers explaining
that Bernie is a terrible candidate
Bernie a lot of what he says the message
is basically you can live your life for
free we'll have free college tuition
will have free this will forgive you
student debts it's a powerful message it
is but in the general election it's a
message that I think is going to get him
killed yeah I mean I've you know think
he's the worst candidate in a general
election for exactly that reason think
Bernie's the worst pianist oh I don't
think there's a question about it okay
so the guns have opened up from Team
Obama on Team Bernie and that is not
particularly surprising but this is the
time for Bernie to fight back this is
his last and this is the Alamo for
Bernie and they say this is where Bernie
has to has to stay this is stalingrad to
use a better analogy because bernie is
indeed a Stalinist the people were
talking about are not Nazis though so I
guess I'll have to think of another
analogy but all right in any case the
fact that the fact that the the
Democrats are going after Bernie and
that they're going after him for the
great sin of unwellness is amusing to me
I am enjoying it and enjoy really enjoy
yourselves guys okay in just a second
we're actually going to do the mailbag
Women's on that in a few weeks so I
would love to take your questions in the
mailbag and we are gonna do that
momentarily first let me talk about the
fact that you will have a better life
when your teeth are straighter you know
it's funny we all we all are very angry
that we live in a society where people
judge each other based on appearance
this is called all of human society
forever
and always will be well one of the
things that you judge people based on is
the beauty of their smile science proves
this is so well if you have teeth that
have fallen out of place since you were
younger or you never got braces the best
way to get those teeth straight looking
real good again is to check out candid I
know because I'm using candid aligners
right now I had braces when I was
younger my teeth are pretty straight but
they slip out of place over the years
and sometimes you need the aligners to
put things back where they should be
well right now go to candid co.com
that's candid co.com
and use / appear oh so I can encode a
comma / appear oh and you get 75 bucks
off those clear
they straighten your teeth for 65% less
than braces they're really easy it's
much better than going to a doctor's
office you can do all of it basically
from the comfort of your own home unlike
other companies Canada only works with
orthodontists never general dentists
that means your treatment will be
designed by an expert in tooth with 20
years of experience on average if you're
looking ahead to a special event this
season now would be the time for you to
get those teeth straight you can do this
in just a few months learn more about
Canada's process get a complimentary 3d
scan of your teeth at a candidate studio
near you which is the simplest freest
way to get started go to candid co.com
slash Shapiro and use code Shapiro for
75 bucks off that is candid co.com slash
apparel use coach Shapiro for that $75
off really solid deal on doing something
you should be doing anyway go get your
teeth straighter at candid co.com slash
capiro use coaching pro for 75 bucks off
I use the the aligners they really are
helping me and the process is super easy
they are very user friendly go check
them out right now at Canada Co comm
slash up hero and use that code Shapiro
for 75 bucks off okay
we're gonna get to the mailbag in just a
second first it is that glorious time of
the week when I give a shout out to a
daily where subscribers it use it you
well a mustard go Joe got show it's not
you but if you are Joe gotcha today is
the day joe gotcha knows there's only
one thing that can help sustain you
through the insanely long lines at theme
parks in this picture Joe and his son
are wearing matching blue Lion King
t-shirts standing out in the hot Sun
proudly carrying our glorious tumbler
the caption reads I don't always do
Disney but when I do I stay hydrated
with the greatest in all beverage
vessels the leftist here is hot or cold
tumbler at ben shapiro hashtag left is
tears tumblr hashtag always full
fantastic good on you Joe hope you and
your family had a great time on your
vacation if you're a Disneyland I hope
they had a good time at galaxies hedge
it's a fun place thank you for the
picture if you know anything about this
show also just while we're at this right
now we have a special deal we are a pro
light show you know the word Pro live
show if you've ever listened to the show
you know this we broadcast live from the
March for Life last year well you may
not know is that because we did that the
leftist activist the same people going
after Joe Rogan today because this is
what they do they decided to go after
our advertisers and we actually lost
some revenue that's not the first time
it won't be the last time that the left
attempts to shut down pro-life of voices
we're not the only targets live action
is a great pro-life group run by my
friend Lila Rose live action is terrific
they work on education on the abortion
issue they make undercover videos that
expose Planned Parenthood and other
abortion clinics for horrific human
rights abuses and
their crackdown routinely by by social
media so Twitter's crack down on them
Pinterest is crack down on them if you
want to help them out there's a great
way to do it and help us out too you can
go to daily wire.com right now and right
now when you subscribe it's daily wire
calm and you use promo code live action
a portion of your subscription
membership is donated to live action
from now until january 31st and
expectation of the march for life so
that's a pretty great deal use promo
code live action and you get our
subscription and give money to a great
cause when you go to daily wire calm and
make your pro life a voice heard we're
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so Chelsea writes we're doing some
mailbag so Chelsea writes Haven
yesterday you talked about how you think
elizabeth warren would be able to push
through universal child care with
increasing frequency Republicans are
warming up to this idea even if they
understand it would be just another step
of the government interfering with and
replacing the family what are the best
arguments against universal childcare
thank you
well actually Elizabeth Warren back in
2003 wrote a book called the two income
trap in which she discussed the problem
with universal childcare one of the
problems with universal childcare is it
now assumes that both members of a
family have to work right that is the
basic premise of universal childcare the
problem with that is that once we have
both members of the family working she
makes this point in the two income trap
is that it actually drives up
real-estate prices it drives up prices
it requires you to earn more in the
market in order to get what you could
have gotten for cheaper before when
there was only one worker in the
household and so what you end up with is
a broader labor pool which does drive
down wages not only does it do that
it requires both members of the family
to be working and then in order to buy
that house in the suburbs that you want
you need both members of the household
working and if you are stay-at-home mom
you are disadvantaged so it does
disadvantage stay-at-home moms
it basically subsidizes working moms at
the expense of stay-at-home moms is the
idea also it subsidizes single moms at
the expense of married moms beyond that
there's a basic premise to universal
child care which is that all women find
fulfilment in working so the best that
you could do maybe if you were if you're
really concerned about this here's a
great idea just lower taxes and then if
people want to pay for childcare they
can pay for childcare and by the way
there are plenty of workplaces right now
that are offering childcare for kids
like seriously they have childcare
downstairs and mom can drop off the kids
for the day after school it'll take care
of it but the idea that Universal
childcare is an inherent good because
mom has to work is an assumption being
made about what mothers should be doing
that I think cuts against the very grain
of female choice in a lot of cases and
beyond that it also creates a weird
economic structure whereby everybody is
expected to work including women so it
actually removes the choice from women
to work or not work in many cases
because now the idea is that you are
expected to work because after all
Universal childcare is available to you
I mean this is the case that that
Elizabeth Warren again herself made
while she is pushing universal childcare
now so she's
yourself on that in some pretty dramatic
ways then there is the general
libertarian argument which is it's none
of my business what you do with your
kids it is your job to take care of your
kids as a general rule now I'm all for
charity I'm all for making sure that
those kids are taken care of and if
you're in economic straits I'm all for
giving you direct charity but the idea
that it is society's job to make sure
that you are working a 10-hour day and
that your child is in childcare also
there's an assumption that child care is
better for kids than being at home with
mom which again I think is not backed by
social science and the notion that a
family is better off of mom and stumping
the kid in child care all day that has
some significant drawbacks as well
now again local communities can do this
but the idea of a federally mandated
universal child care in which we are all
supposed to pay in and that's going to
cover everybody it doesn't the buys it
creates a perverse incentive it creates
a perverse incentive for people to take
advantage of the universal child care
and again makes the the government into
mommy which is not a good idea Michael
says hey man if the Chief Justice is
presiding over the impeachment trial why
can't he be the deciding factor and
calling witnesses loved the show thanks
well the way that these procedures
usually work is that the the Senate
actually has to vote for the procedures
it's not up to the Chief Justice to vote
for the procedures he just gavels in
whether the procedures have been applied
or not right he makes sure that the
procedures are actually followed but
he's not the one who makes the rules the
Senate makes the rules so it's not up to
the Chief Justice to do that Tim says I
hear the terms communism socialism and
Marxism often used seemingly
interchangeably could you briefly
explain the differences between them or
is it all one thing that in the future
we could call Bernie ISM well the
problem is that folks on the Left like
to distinguish between these things
based on whether they think it's
successful or not
so what you'll hear from Marxists is
that they're very there are many types
of Marxism but there is guild Marxism
that there is sort of Trotskyite Marxism
and there is Stalin Marxism that there
is Cuban Marxism and there's Norwegian
Marxism but these are all different
forms of Marxism that's a way of hiding
the ball that's so that you don't
actually have to be pegged down when
Marxism is actually tried in a country
like Cuba or the USSR you can just say
well that's not true Marxism true
Marxism has never been tried and the
same thing holds true with communism so
communism it's hard for the Democrats or
anybody on the left to as a Marxist to
run away from the communist label
anymore because communist countries ones
that have self declared communists have
been complete failures every time and
try
so instead what they try to do is
distinguish socialism from communism and
the reality is that if you're calling
for public ownership of the means of
production then what you are really
talking about is communism while you're
talking about is is socialism communism
Marxism they're all equivalent in this
way this has been a long-standing sort
of confused debate von Mises writes
about it in his book socialism from 1920
he suggests that really if you're gonna
define Marxism Marxism in the end is not
even about the principle from each
according to his abilities to each
according to his needs
it really is about the public ownership
of the means of production and there are
a lot of aspects to Marxism and
different aspects can be analyzed on
their own or in combination but the root
of economic Marxism is the idea that we
cannot have private industry because
private industry is profit driven
profits are bad because they are excess
and because you are stealing from the
workers and the only way to remove those
excess profits is to have the workers
own the business but not in a private
market instead you have to have the
government run everything to make sure
that work because workers could be just
as capitalists into anybody else instead
the government has to decide supply
demand the government has set aside
pricing the government has to create a
pricing mechanism all of this is utterly
unworkable on a practical level so what
you see is aspects of like kind of kind
of food coloring of Marxism dropped into
a capitalist and then called Marxism so
you'll see is people on the Left say
well democratic socialism is Marxism it
is not ok a capitalist system with
socialist welfare benefits is a
capitalist system with socialist welfare
benefits and then we can determine
whether the socialist welfare benefits
actually achieve what they are seeking
to achieve so nationalized healthcare
system is in fact socialism I mean that
is a socialist system but if it exists
in the context of a free market for
drugs for doctors if it exists in a free
market in general that is drawing from
taxpayer revenue then you have to
distinguish between the socialist aspect
and the not socialist aspect socialism
is basically the idea that they the
entire capitalist system should be
overthrown I mean that is the basis of
Marxism now again you can have welfare
benefits welfare benefits are socialist
in orientation but if the system is not
itself socialist then it's not a
socialist system it Ryan says hey Ben
I'm 17 years old from Massachusetts I
listen to all three hours of your show
every day I'm like Greta thumb burg I do
not hold global warming is one of my
highest priorities it honestly doesn't
worry me all that much however I've
researched
nuclear power is a possible energy
source it appears to be the best
solution I've come across what are your
thoughts on nuclear power do you think
any further steps that need to be taken
to stop global warming sure I mean I
global warming my best available
evidence is occurring it is largely man
caused by best available evidence even
people who are sort of lukewarm errs
like Roy Spencer we've heard on on Rush
Limbaugh's program for example even he
will say he believes that over 50% of
global warming is being caused by
man-made activities and glue and carbon
emissions so I don't believe these sort
of full-on denial case at all what
should we do about that well the best
answer honestly is not going to be a
global carbon tax which is never going
to take place China and India will never
sign on to that and it won't be
effective without China and India
signing on to it instead what will be
effective is actual economic development
by the substitution of natural gas for
for oil in the United States has been
responsible for the United States
actually dropping its carbon emissions
its rate of carbon emissions over the
last several years you will also knew
how is an excellent solution there are
new smaller nuclear plants that can be
built using newer technology that's
basically been stymied by the
environmentalists if you want to know if
an environmentalist is serious or not
about climate change just ask if they're
trying to ban nuclear power if the
answer is they're trying to ban nuclear
power they're not serious about climate
change most of the people who say
they're serious about climate change are
not in fact serious about climate change
they don't want to talk about adaptation
they don't want to talk about building
sea walls they don't want to talk about
about the possibility of carbon capture
they don't want to talk about any of
those things they just want to rail
against the moon and that's why they
love Greta Thun berg because she will
say things openly like we should just
get rid of all carbon-based fossil fuels
on planet earth and not use them anymore
which would reduce pretty much everybody
back to the level of our Homo erectus
ancestors in terms of living standards
it would not be wonderful Larry says
dear Ben what do you think of the notion
that the electoral college should move
away from a winner-take-all system and
instead proportionally allocate
electoral votes it seems like this would
make candidates focus on states that are
not swing states is this beneficial well
the whole purpose of the electoral
college originally was to balance out
the needs of states and the needs of the
population generally and it's it's sort
of the same balance that you see in
terms of the United States Congress and
we ourselves today very often don't even
understand why the states ought to
matter because we've lost the concept
to federalism in localism entirely CC
Democrats militating against the United
States Senate saying the United States
Senate is not representative after all
Montana has as many votes in the Senate
as California and Montana has nine
people in California has 50 million so
what exactly why are we doing that the
answer is the proportional
representation makes states irrelevant
and states never would have signed on to
the Constitution if they had if they had
known that they were going to become
adjuncts to basically they're gonna be
barnacles on the whales of California
and New York and Massachusetts in New
Jersey and all the big population states
so the Electoral College I do not think
it should be proportionally allocated I
think if you want to do that just go to
a popular vote it doesn't seem to
actually mean anything to be
proportionally allocated beyond just a
reflection of the popular vote already
time for a quick thing that I like and
then a quick a thing that I hate so
things that I like today there's a good
movie that was really under covered I
enjoyed it I think that it was really
well made I'm a sucker for westerns so I
really like westerns this is a pretty
good western then it was not greatly
covered by the media the media didn't
seem to like it very much I'm not sure
why honestly like this is it's a pretty
it's a pretty good Western it's a really
interesting take on I'm Billy the Kid so
if you don't know anything about the
about Billy the Kid shot to death at age
21 but his record of killing was a lot
more checkered than most of these sort
of criminals of the of American history
never robbed a bank
they never robbed a train he was not in
fact there there's real controversy as
to just how much of a criminal Billy the
Kid was because he was really involved
more in sort of farming disputes and
neighbor disputes and then there were
some disputed circumstances where he was
killing other bad men in any case the
the basic premise of the film is that is
that there's a kid who he and his sister
are present when his father is beating
his mother and the kid shoots the father
and then tries to escape run away with
his sister they're sort of taken under
wing by Billy the Kid Pat Garrett is is
chasing Billy the Kid at the time and
the and so all of this takes place in
the context of that very very famous
pursuit here's a little bit of the
trailer
you think she'd be run for me that one
has to tie style ain't that one of
life's partialities
one more step and it will be your last
so Chris Pratt shows up moving five
seconds and they sort of pitched him as
one of the stars of the film he's only
in it for maybe 10 minutes the real bad
guy it's it there is no real bad guy in
the film he's the only true body and the
Feldman's Chris Pratt and he's
unrecognizable
like if you didn't know that was Chris
Pratt you'd be surprised that's press
press I happen to be a big Ethan Hawke
fan you have to be a fan of sort of
mannered acting too like Ethan Hawke but
I like Ethan Hawke a lot and he's very
good in this film
so it is it's worthy of the watch the
kid also my good friend Adam Baldwin
isn't in this movie so any any movie
with Adam is worth watching so go check
it out the kid with Ethan Hawke kind of
a fun thing already time for you know
instead of a thing I hate let's do a
little bit of Bible talk I've missed it
the last several weeks so every week the
Jews read a portion of the Bible and
this week the Jews read from the book of
Exodus this is the portion of the Bible
in which the Jews are basically
preparing to leave Egypt and Moses goes
and he's threatening he's threatening
Pharaoh and he's telling him that if you
don't let the Jews go things are gonna
get real bad for you real quick right
quick here so there's a really
interesting part of this week's partial
right this is this particular Torah
portion that is the the bizarre
statement that God says he's going to
harden Pharaoh's heart already says that
Pharaoh is gonna be willing to let you
go and I'm gonna harden his heart and
people all the commentators in Jewish
lore and Christian lore - they go like
how is that a thing that is not supposed
to interfere with your free well why is
God getting involved in hardening
Pharaoh's heart to make him do a bad
thing right why is it that God is
telling ferret-like Pharaoh's willing to
let the Jews go and then this whole
thing comes to a sort of natural denuo
mall instead
why is God hardening Pharaoh's heart
it's very bizarre I mean God says I
shall harden Pharaoh's heart and I shall
put my hand upon Egypt and I shall take
out my legions the children of Israel
from the land of Egypt so how can you
harden Pharaoh's heart and hold him
responsible for what he's doing
right because that's what happens right
Pharaoh is held responsible
his army dies in the sea things go real
bad so why would God do that well God
acknowledges in the Torah first I so
this brings up questions of free will
generally how much free will do human
beings actually have this is pretty live
question right in the scientific
community it's a live question how much
do we actually have the ability to
control our own actions how much of that
is environmental right mark Sussman
let's say it's all environmental it's
all environment in biology determines
everything and then they say we can
magically change our own system using
free will right we can supplant
capitalism with communism and that will
change the social system and then we
will all be better people
so they contradict their own philosophy
in the middle of their philosophy but
these sort of materialist point of view
generally is that we don't have any free
well this has led some really
interesting debates between me and Sam
Harris another person who is no longer
welcome in the hard left for having
conversations and people Sam takes the
materialist position that we don't have
any free well I take the position that
we do have free will and that we have
the ability to overcome to at least a
certain extent our own biological drives
in order to make better decisions
Sam takes the position the basically are
screwed right I mean whatever whatever
you are you are whatever decisions you
think you're making you're not making
those decisions that is your biology in
conjunction with your environment so how
much free will do we actually have well
the Torah suggests that man is a
biological creature but then also
suggests that biology does not determine
man's fate right that you actually do
have the capacity to make decisions
beyond your own biological imperatives
so the question is when God hardens
Pharaoh's heart does God actually is he
actually making the decision for Pharaoh
or is he making it easier for Pharaoh to
make a decision because there's another
way to read hardens Pharaoh's heart one
way is to read it as God is making it so
that Pharaoh says no the other way is to
read it that God is stealing Pharaoh for
what is to come right the God is saying
okay I understand that you're afraid I
understand that you are living in fear
of the next plague but this is actually
making it harder for you to make the
decision that you want to make and I
know what kind of decision you actually
want to make so instead I'm making you
braver right if you'd heard that
somebody in battle hardened their heart
you would figure okay this guy just got
wrecked he had it he was brave now now
he had he'd put aside his fear and he
was more brave so when the Bible says
that God hardens Pharaoh's heart what
he's actually doing is he's giving
Pharaoh the capacity to choose more
broadly he is saying I know what you
want to do and I'm giving you the
capacity to choose more broadly so God
is actually changing Pharaoh in order to
allow him more freedom of choice so in
in that same way this is basically what
psychologists do every day when they
engage in cognitive behavioral therapy
or exposure therapy they're hoping you
get over whatever fear you have so that
you have more freedom of choice
available to you
so this is how God free it gives us free
well right he limits his own control
it's not that he is telling Pharaoh what
to do he's limiting his own control by
giving Pharaoh a greater capacity for
free well so what exactly is free well
and why should it matter well in
politics it matters an awful lot you
cannot build a system on anything other
than free well we assume in our politics
that free will is the is the be-all
end-all that's why we feel that personal
responsibility is a thing and if you
want people to have a better life you
have to give them credit for their own
free will you cannot tell them they are
environmentally driven right you try to
steal them for they see don't be afraid
make your own decisions in this case
peril of Pharaoh Paro makes the wrong
decision in this case he feels stronger
to make the decision he makes a bad
decision but what we should be doing in
our normal lives is giving people the
capacity to make decisions for which
they end up taking responsibility social
psychologist Roy Baumeister he explains
what science is mean by free will he
says self-control counts is a kind of
freedom because it begins with not
acting on every impulse the use of
abstract ideas such as moral principles
to guide action takes us far beyond
anything you'll find in a physics or
chemistry textbook and so we are free
and the sense of emergence of going
beyond simpler forms of causality again
we cannot break the laws of physics but
we can act in ways they add new causes
that go far beyond physical causation
now when I talk about free well I don't
mean that every decision is subject to
it right you can't decide right now
whether your heart should beat or not
right I mean that part is natural as a
part of your brain but it does mean that
when we make plans that when we think
things through we are capable of
changing our own behavior this is why
pharaohs still bears responsibility for
his actions so what we should be doing
as a society is granting people the
capacity to make freer decisions telling
them that they have the strength to make
their own decisions and then holding
them responsible for their decisions if
it's good enough for God and Pharaoh it
should be good enough for us as well
okay we'll be back here later today with
a couple additional hours of content all
your updates on impeachment and all the
rest i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the Benton Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy Boren senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director pavel itäôs key
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nyx even
associate producer katie swenerton
edited by adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Romina hair and makeup is by
Anika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 25 on the Matt Walsh oh we're
not just discussing politics we're
talking culture faith family all of the
things that are really important to you
so come join the conversation
[Music]
you